[Music]
alan is in louisville kentucky hi alan
how are you
hi dave and john i'm doing better every
day what an honor to talk to both of you
you too sir how can we help well i'll be
i'll be quick i'm not here to waste
anybody's time i'll give you the context
and then the question
um i'm 24 married got one child mixed 60
000 a year in union construction right
now however i'm on total temporary
disability roughly three months ago i
was buried in a building collapsed and
buried uh totally alive
due to the work of the co-workers and
firefighters that got me out within two
hours and saved my legs within five
minutes
so i'm back home i'm out of the
wheelchair i'm in therapy um there i
still got probably another four weeks
until i start doing some light duty
stuff
um broke leg and shoulder and had a
small brain bleed was on ventilator for
a little bit some other
other stuff but um the questions i've
got for you
i've retained lawyers for other stuff
but it kind of revolves around if and if
there's anything ruled negligent which
is kind of what you're thinking i'm sure
um is
as far as the settlement why is you know
how long do i wait i'm renting right now
um
you know i don't have fancy cars i got
what i need i've i was in baby step two
right now i've got about five thousand
savings and i've got 2 500 in past
medical debt obviously everything's
being taken care of as far as i'm on i'm
on disability and then everything's
being covered by workers comp just those
main two questions is just you know how
long do i wait if there's a settlement
and then do i pay off that 2500 that
i've gotten
past medical debt
um i was in the baby step two i've been
through ipu i've used your elps for
everything from my taxes to my insurance
i've got disability insurance i felt
like it was done you've been through it
you've been through it
it's it's been interesting
it was an amazing
adventure that you've been on man
right how long ago how long ago was the
accident
well it was in end of february so it's
been just over three months wow
i've been walking here for about two
weeks so you're up walking now
yes yep up walking i've got surgery
coming up here in two or three days
they're going to take a screw out of my
knee that's kind of messing with my walk
and that should get a little better but
that should be the end of that it said
the brain bleed you're a tough motor
scooter how are you managing the pain
um well uh or off of percocet so we're
just on tylenol now so we're never going
back right
that's that's the plan yeah no no no no
no no no i was on there we're never
going back we're never going back right
correct correct there you go percocet
makes buildings fly yeah yeah good for
you yeah the percocet before that
cutting means a little hard on you and
dilaudid and all that yes
yes yes
yeah you got messed up
sorry man i'm glad you're lucky i'm glad
your little girl's got her daddy with
her
right
so uh yeah it's just i couldn't find
anybody on youtube that had the scenario
that i did outside of maybe inheritance
questions but i'm just looking for some
counsel
huh um it's early
to have this discussion because right
now i'm just happy you're up walking
around i'm out of breath listening to
you
the um but but
you know a year from today two years
from today five years from today
what are you what are you have you
thought that far out on what you're
gonna be doing for a living well i i
continued as far as the relationship
with the employers you know still been
great they you know they're grateful for
everything it you know it's still under
investigation to exactly what happened i
was the only one with their building
that fell in if we're a general
contractor and i'm a union
carpenter
and we're working on a project that's
you know about 30 some buildings it's a
big campus about 800 million the company
itself runs about 500 uh guys in the
field that you work for but so the if
there is negligence it's the company you
work for
um
at this point the lawyers it's third
party you can't sue your own employer
um
so it's it's kind of looking like uh
excavators um i work in you know heavy
concrete as far as foundation wise
and what seems to have happened is you
know we came in the same day that they
dug out dirt to do some you know
foundation work and then the foundation
blew out and buried me so
that's
as far as that so you think long term
with your injury you'll recover enough
to go back to doing your job
uh i do um the doctor already said you
know i tore three rotator cuffs and a
bicep so overhead stuff's probably not
really gonna be in there but i love the
industry i love working with people you
know this
is
it's not my plans to move away from this
type of injury without kind of answering
the question and so you'll be back to
making an income similar to who you used
to make
but yeah there's workers comp and
workers comp and disability will cover
you until then
yeah workers comp they're getting to me
with within a hundred dollars of my
paycheck where i was
so mathematically if i'm understanding
alan here's what i'm trying to get my
head around
mathematically if i'm understanding
you go from disability workers comp to
back to working again over some period
of time
and you're going to have the same income
as you had before the accident
everything's going to be running right
along so any settlement that you get
would be to cover
any more surgeries that you have to do
or any other injuries that anything you
have to do regarding the injury
or
um
it's just gravy you don't really need
the money your life is going to go on
like it was before the accident and the
money that you get mathematically
speaking will be just to uh
will just cause you to have a
gravy on the biscuit to you know to have
a little extra right
right so my point my point is how long
do you wait for money that you didn't
need anyway as long as you need to wait
to get the maximum amount
and so as far as your attorneys that are
advising you on this negligence lawsuit
can tell you what the timeline looks
like and if it's four years
it really doesn't matter because you're
going to have the same income anyway
and you're going to be moving right
along am i missing something
right i was just kind of thinking you
know if it's something crazy like a
million dollars you know is there a
timeline that you wait to let that kind
of soak in no or it doesn't really
matter it's already that timeline's
already been used up by then no you
you're you're gonna you're gonna have a
long timeline
they don't give up a million dollars a
few years they don't give up a million
dollars easy it's gonna take a while and
remember this and you don't have to have
it to eat yeah and the idea of a
settlement yeah the idea of a settlement
is to make you whole
not a
it's not a scratch-off ticket it's not
you didn't hit a lottery ticket right
and so right you might get a million
dollars but you just said it um in
passing this is going to cost you some
this is going to shave some of some of
your life off right um this is going to
affect you 20 years from now with a hip
replacement or 30 years with a knee
replace right so you want to bank some
of that stuff and be smart about it
don't think oh cool we can buy ferraris
now right or now we can buy a house with
it yeah not even um so i would continue
your life as if you weren't getting a
settlement
and then if you get one it's just extra
money that's my point
and then it then the timeline doesn't
matter as much you're not waiting to buy
a house on this settlement you're not
waiting to do something on this
settlement because you're not waiting on
the settlement you're moving on with
your life
man i'm sorry for what you have sorry
i'm glad you're terrible